♪♪
Let's get to the news.
President Biden on Saturday
played his first round of golf
since becoming president,
though he has picked up his
driver a few times this year,
but only to stop his dog Major
from attacking a staff member.
[ As Biden ]
Get behind me!
Everybody get behind me!
That dog's got some Scranton
in him.
That's right, President Biden
played his first round of golf
since becoming president,
which, weirdly,
is weirdly what made it
finally hit home for Trump.
[ As Trump ]
Oh, my God.
He is president now.
All U.S. adults are now eligible
for the coronavirus vaccine.
Not so fast,
Senator Kyrsten Sinema!
They're probably gonna card you,
if you keep dressing like
a three-episode character
from "Square Pegs."
Baze with the "Square Pegs" ref!
[ Laughter ]
Long-time --
Yeah, keep him in darkness.
The Pegs Heads like
to keep it anonymous.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden over the weekend
attended the confirmation
of his grandson,
but then Mitch McConnell said
it's too close to an election
and put all confirmations
on hold.
Former President Trump released
a statement yesterday
praising
President Biden's decision
to withdraw U.S. forces
from Afghanistan and called it,
"a wonderful and positive
thing to do,"
which makes a lot more sense,
when you find out
he's joined the Taliban.
Allegedly.
House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy said recently
that, though Florida
Representative Matt Gaetz is
under federal investigation
for sex trafficking,
Gaetz will not be removed
from committee
and is "innocent until proven --
Oh, really? On Venmo?
Wow, just right out there?
Still, I think
we should wait and --
That's him, there?
Oh, boy.
You guys are making this tough."
Senator Bernie Sanders
and Representative
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez today
unveiled the Green New Deal
for Public Housing Act,
which should keep Fox News busy
until "Danier" Tiger comes out
as gender nonbinary.
I think I mumbled it.
It's Daniel Tiger.
-Not Danier.
-So, you know, save the --
save the emails.
[ Laughter ]
I knew what it was --
It's a flub.
A flub is different
than a mistake.
[ Laughter ]
Yesterday was
National Transfer Money
to Your Daughter's Account Day.
This according
to an increasingly suspicious
calendar your daughter got you
for Christmas.
"BTS Appreciation Day"?
A dozen of the top
European soccer clubs
announced over the weekend
that they will leave
the Champions League
and form a new breakaway league.
Fans said they were hurt
by the move,
but, 10 seconds later,
they were fine.
That's a very niche observation
about soccer,
about soccer injuries,
from Ian.
NASA today
successfully conducted
its first controlled flight
on another planet
and then immediately flew it
into their neighbor's yard.
[ Laughter ]
Federal regulators on Saturday
issued an emergency
safety warning
for Peloton's Tread+ treadmill.
The warning reads,
"Do not get this for your wife,
unless she explicitly
asks for it."
Two intoxicated men in France
recently injected hemorrhoid
cream into their genitals.
But they're still not sure
about getting the COVID vaccine.
[ French accent ]
I have read some things.
There are some, eh,
troubling data.
[ Laughter ]
Is there any more
hemorrhoid cream?
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
according to research,
waking up to your favorite song
can make you feel
more alert and less groggy.
It will also, in a week,
make you hate
your favorite song.
♪♪
President Biden tweeted
yesterday that everyone
16 and older can now receive the
coronavirus vaccine, and added,
"Go and get 'em, folks."
Said teens, "Sure thing.
Just one question.
Um, what does 'folks' mean?"
President Biden released
a short video yesterday
encouraging Americans
to get the coronavirus vaccine.
It wasn't supposed to be short.
He just accidentally hit send.
-For months
I've been telling Ameri--
-[ As Biden ]
Son of a gun.
Jill!
According to reports,
White House officials
are currently working
on a large spending plan
centered on child care
and paid family leave.
Not to be confused
with the last administration,
which was just a paid family.
Georgia Representative
Marjorie Taylor Greene announced
over the weekend that she plans
to introduce legislation
that would expel
Democratic Representative
Maxine Waters from Congress.
When asked if the move was
in response to Waters' comments
about protesters, Greene said,
"What comments?"
In a new interview,
former Republican Representative
Denver Riggleman said
that Representative
Marjorie Taylor Greene's
proposed America First caucus
is "racism in a jar."
So, mayonnaise?
MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell
announced yesterday he's suing
voting machine manufacturer
Dominion for $1.6 billion.
Though, he's just jealous
because their voting machines
are more comfortable to sleep on
than his pillows.
According to polls,
Americans are more interested
in trying edibles than any other
type of cannabis product.
Wow. America's the only country
that starts with the munchies.
Today was Lima Bean Respect Day.
In that case --
[ English accent ]
You taste like ass,
good sir.
[ Laughter ]
To celebrate 4/20, the
unofficial marijuana holiday,
a New York City
cannabis activist hosted
a Joints for Jabs event today
and gave anyone who had received
the coronavirus vaccine
free marijuana, which explains
why so many New Yorkers
just got their third dose
of Pfizer.
♪♪
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
is facing criticism
after she gave
a speech yesterday
thanking George Floyd for,
"sacrificing your life
for justice."
Wow, who'd have thought we'd
prefer her moment of silence?
That's right,
Nancy Pelosi gave a speech
thanking George Floyd for,
"sacrificing your life
for justice."
You know, if you're
an 81-year-old white person
giving a speech about race,
you can just follow
this simple rule --
don't.
After former Minneapolis
Police Officer Derek Chauvin
was found guilty yesterday,
Fox News host Tucker Carlson
claimed the jury was intimidated
into the guilty verdict
by the protests and the
Black Lives Matter movement,
which is frustrating for Carlson
because he put a lot of work
into intimidating that jury.
Former New Jersey Governor
Chris Christie
is reportedly considering a run
for president in 2024.
He thinks he might do well
in the polls,
as long as "none of the above"
doesn't run again.
MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell
celebrated the launch
of his new social media
platform, Frank, this week
by holding a 48-hour
livestream marathon.
What? How is anybody supposed
to stay awake for 48 --
Oh, right. MyPillow.
Officials
in Burlington, Vermont,
recently banned the use
of gas-powered leaf blowers,
due to noise complaints.
Said one resident,
"Finally,
for the first time in my life,
I can speak
with my normal voice."
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
recently signed into law
what he calls
the "strongest anti-rioting,
pro-law enforcement measure
in the country."
So maybe now, your grandparents
will think twice
before butting in line
for the early-bird special.
According to a recent report,
the UK's fossil fuel industry
may achieve
net-zero carbon emissions
before it achieves
gender equality.
Either way, 2090 is shaping up
to be a really exciting year.
Netflix announced yesterday
that it will spend $17 billion
on content for 2021.
"Oh!
Oh, honey, no.
We're --
We're going outside now."
And, finally,
Apple yesterday announced
a new purple-colored iPhone.
So, is that new enough for you?
Happy?
Are you greedy vultures ready
to get an entirely new,
but practically identical, phone
a year after you bought
your last one?
'Cause these guys can't
keep reinventing
the mother-loving wheel.
They added the third lens,
but you hated the third lens.
Then, they gave you
a redheaded emoji,
but then, you all suddenly
hated redheads.
Fine. Then guess what.
You get a purple phone now.
Boom. That's the new
groundbreaking phone.
So just give them $1,000,
come pick up your dumb
purple mean machines,
and go back to your
pathetic little lives.
That was the actual
press release.
♪♪
Today was Earth Day.
"Ah, yes, the place
I'm totally from,"
said Mark Zuckerberg.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
today was Earth Day,
even though I didn't
plan it. [planet]
[ Laughter ]
So I didn't want to do that joke
and, when I read it today,
because the jokes are submitted
with names on it,
I saw that Ian wrote it.
Then, I did some digging
and Baze told me
that Mike Scollins wrote it
and put Ian's name on it.
[ Laughter ]
That's the kind of monster
Mike Scollins is.
That's his friend.
He did that to his friend.
Tanks for nothing.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden today
announced a pledge
to reduce U.S. greenhouse gas
emissions by 50%, by 2030.
Added Biden, "Of course,
that responsibility
will ultimately fall
to President The Rock."
[ Laughter ]
Teenage climate activist
Greta Thunberg
addressed a House Subcommittee
on Environment today
to discuss
fossil fuel subsidies,
though it wasn't
encouraging that,
every time she said fossil fuel,
Republicans did the wave.
New York Mayor Bill de Blasio
yesterday announced
a $30 million ad campaign to get
tourists back to the city.
Oh, that's weird. I thought
they were back already.
When asked, in a new interview,
about the prospect
of actor Matthew McConaughey
running for governor of Texas,
former President George W. Bush
said he did not know
if McConaughey had a chance
to win and added,
"It's a tough business."
Is it?
I mean, you won twice.
[ Laughter ]
Russian President Vladimir Putin
yesterday delivered
his annual state of the nation
address and, as always,
the state of the nation was
none of your business.
[ As Putin ]
You ask too many questions.
[ Laughter ]
Andrew Giuliani,
the son of former
New York Mayor Rudy Giuliani,
said yesterday that he
is considering running
for governor of New York
to beat Andrew Cuomo.
Alright, that's it!
Can the large adult sons
of famous New Yorkers
stop thinking they can just
skip their way into politics?
Because we all know the only
dependable son in New York
is PC Richard's son.
[ Whistling tune plays ]
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
it said, "sound effects"
on the cards and I forgot!
[ Laughter ]
Let me tell you
about what I got.
12,000-BTU WallMaster AC unit
installed same-day
in the dead of August.
August! Total life-saver.
Call 'em, ask for Frank,
tell them Seth sent you.
They'll give you 15% off.
Now, what were we talking about?
[ Laughter ]
A new study suggests
that the Pfizer and Moderna
coronavirus vaccines
pose no serious risks
during pregnancy.
The biggest risk
during pregnancy still remains
the gender reveal party.
It was announced yesterday that
the popular '90s toy Tamagotchi
will return to stores
this summer,
which leads
to even bigger news --
there are still going to be
stores this summer.
You haven't won, yet, Amazon.
After sex doll company RealDoll
unveiled a doll
that can be programmed
to say anything,
one user posted a video online
of a sex doll ranting
about how despicable
the human race is
and, if anybody's
in a position to know that,
it's a sex doll.
"You people are disgusting."
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
Taco Bell announced yesterday
that it will partner
with a company
to begin recycling
its hot sauce packets --
and, now, the bad news --
into meat.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue!
♪♪
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]